thomas donald trump est actuellement à
bord de l'avion présidentiel mais juste
avant de s'envoler pour la floride et la
tenue un ultime discours en tant que
président des états unis
[Musique]
oui les derniers mots de donald trump en
tant que locataire de la maison blanche
il est donc ce matin juste avant son
départ pour la floride il a souhaité
bonne chance à la nouvelle
administration de joe biden il a
également vanté son bilan ses quatre
années passées à la présidence des états
unis et puis dans un message un peu plus
énigmatique il a expliqué qu'il
reviendrait je propose d'écouter cet
extrait de son discours je me battrai
toujours pour vous je regarderai
j'écouterai et je vous dirais que le
futur de ce pays n'a jamais été aussi
bon je souhaite à la nouvelle
administration beaucoup de chance
beaucoup de succès je pense qu'elle aura
beaucoup de succès elle a de bonnes
fondations pour faire des choses
vraiment spectaculaire et je le redis
nous l'avons mise dans des conditions
telles que ça n'a jamais été fait
auparavant et ce malgré la pire pandémie
qui nous est frappé depuis je suppose
1917 en dépit de cela ce que nous avons
fait a été incroyable et nous n'aurions
pas pu le faire sans vous donc c'est
juste un au revoir je vous aime je
reviendrai d'une manière ou d'une autre
[Musique]
et on a appris également ce matin que
donald trump avait laissé lettre à
l'attention de son successeur le contenu
de cette lettre n'est pas encore connue
à cette heure de son côté joe biden a
twitté en se réveillant ce matin qu'un
jour nouveau se lève sur l'amérique il
se rend actuellement à une messe à la
cathédrale sainte matthews de washington
et il devrait arriver d'ici une heure
maintenant ici au capitole pour le
lancement de cette cérémonie
d'investiture qui devrait commencer à
11h15 heure locale et qui est c'est à
midi que joe biden devrait prêter
serment officiellement on connaît aussi
un peu plus maintenant en détail les
premières mesures que devrait prendre
joe biden en tant que président des
états unis en une série de 10 cette
mesure qui vise notamment à détricoter
un certain nombre de politiques mises en
place par donald trump parmi les mesures
qui sont cités par les médias américains
ont pour annoter et bien la
réintégration des accords de paris sur
le climat la fin du muslim ban ou encore
l'arrêt du chantier de construction du
mur à la frontière entre les etats-unis
et le mexique évidemment cette cérémonie
d'investiture se tient dans un contexte
particulier à plusieurs égards d'abord
parce qu'il ya évidemment cette pandémie
de kobe de 19
et puis il n'y aura donc pas de foule
devant la devant le capitole aujourd'hui
pas de spectateurs pas de parade dans
les rues pour le jeu bayonne et puis il
ya le contexte sécuritaire on a beaucoup
parlé avec ces menaces notamment
exprimée par m
ces craintes autour de manifestations
potentiellement violente avec des
individus potentiellement armé c'est la
raison pour laquelle la ville de
washington est barricadé et quadrillée
par les forces de l'ordre depuis
plusieurs jours 25 mille membres de la
garde nationale ont été déployés pour
cette journée d'investiture avec
également des profils qui ont été passés
au peigne fin par les autorités par
l'administration militaire on a appris
hier qu'une dizaine de membres de la
garde nationale ont finalement été
écarté du dispositif de sécurité
d'aujourd'hui en raison de lien avec ce
qui est présenté comme des milices
d'extrême droite
il n'avait vraisemblablement pas prévu
d'actions violentes contre joe biden
aujourd'hui mais par précaution les
autorités ont décidé de les écarter du
dispositif
merci thomas bonnet merci également à
l'uqat ua qui vous accompagne aux états
unis pour cette journée particulière
évidemment on vous retrouve tout au long
de cette journée pour commenter cette
cérémonie d'investiture